you get your beauty sleep
time you got up
[Music]
and then see
in a city that lets you get by with our
buddies
[Music]
balance friendship love
[Music]
the hell else we supposed to fight for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh crap sorry we're on um i was actually
thinking of a non-scripted way in order
to tell you about something awesome
which is roadtrace and you can play it
later today
on your phone yes on android or ios it's
coming it's free to play and has no
microtransactions and it's freaking
awesome as you probably saw it on your
screen gabe did you see this i have i've
seen early versions of it too freaking
amazing it's very cool yes and you
played in the game in the cyberpunk game
yeah yeah and now we can also play her
on your phone perfect we'll talk about
more later i guess yeah we will um yeah
but enough about that all right we're
here to talk about you no we're here to
talk about the game yes
but i'll introduce myself yes if you
could and tell everybody what you're
responsible for when it comes to
cyberpunk 2070 sure my name is gabe
amatangelo i'm a game director of
cyberpunk 2077 post launch for the
updates and the upcoming expansion
upcoming
expansion what what
i did the stewie i did the stewie turn
we'll get to that though all right all
right we'll get yes we will uh but about
that like before we get to all that
let's talk about let's kind of go back
in time let's talk about the past and
the updates that were happening for
cyberpunk 2077
um
so what in your opinion is kind of the
landmark update for the game um that you
think had the biggest influence like
there was a lot of stuff going on
recently
well i'd say it's combination 1.5 and
1.3 a ton of bug fixes
also sort of a
kind of
overhaul and re-architecture for a bunch
of fundamental systems
to get it working smooth across all
platforms as well as to set the stage
for for future features and updates and
stuff like that so you started about 1.5
i want to continue with that what's your
feeling about cyberpunk 2077 and how the
game feels and looks right now after
that update
good good i think um uh like i said we
we we smoothed out a bunch of stuff and
i think cyberpunk 2077 can be kind of
fully
uh experienced as intended
uh for you know the the world this
characters enjoying the story that kind
of stuff we also had an opportunity to
get in some of the community requested
features such as going to the mirror in
your apartment and being able to do some
cosmetic updates uh being able to get
new apartments and customize them to
some extent a bunch of different uh
little things like cleaning up uh the
map the the user experience getting rid
of some of the pain points in general uh
just to kind of smooth out the
experience the real flow was kind of bug
fixing or focus i should say bug fixing
smoothing out the experience and getting
the architecture in place for future
updates
and then of course of course sorry to
interrupt but of course of course the
actual sort of next-gen kind of fidelity
with the different visual modes and
stuff like that uh beautiful very dense
night city um and very moody night city
being able to experience them in the
next-gen consoles as well as pc um
huge hugely beautiful dude now i just
want to say i'm even more excited to
replay the game myself once again um so
yeah thank you thank you for that um so
we're talking about the present so we
have the edgerunners update which is
freaking amazing we saw the mashup
trailer uh with similarities between the
anime as well as uh what what we kind of
see in cyberpunk 2077 now
what will we see with this update that
connects edge runners to the world of
2077. so yeah really fun cooperation
with the with the anime as we saw just
like stuff straight out of straight out
of night city world there in the game uh
you'll be able to get martinez's jacket
whereas uh it takes place during the
same kind of timeline they don't they
don't cross paths but we do have a quest
that kind of seeds in some of the stuff
on some of the easter eggs from the the
anime uh you'll be able to get a weapon
inspired by the anime as well which is
fun so a number of different kind of
easter eggs and kind of tie-ins in that
way what about things that are not
connected to the anime because i know
there's a couple really really cool
things that you wanted to highlight for
this update yeah yeah yeah wardrobe
that's the big one right nice aka
transmog aka being able to completely
customize and tailor your outfits as you
want to role play slot by slot to kind
of override the the visuals of what you
currently have equipped we have that we
also update the ripper docks that you go
to them and do some resculpting of your
face resculpting of your body
we added new options in entirely for all
this stuff as well as some of the
cosmetics and hair and stuff like that
you can still do it your mirror you can
also do that at the ripper dock as well
um there's a bunch of things in this
update i would say we're releasing those
patterns check out the patch notes xbox
series s
new mode as requested by the community
um and of course road race it's the
first of our sort of in-game arcade
cabinets that you can actually play in
the game uh and you're playing as that
mythical beast from a faraway land named
after a fish and not a uh smoking
paraphernalia or a gross bug but a fish
this is this is what the ip gods have
told me yes true true and nibbles the
cat in photo mode yes yes nimble's the
cat in photo mode in various different
positions and stuff like that exactly
customized yeah so post your pictures
yeah perfect um moving on now more into
the future what can we expect in terms
of upcoming updates for cyberpunk 2077
any teases for us what's in the future
sure yeah so uh 1.6 is the last major
update for the old gen consoles uh going
forward uh we're remember i was talking
about we're kind of overhauling some
systems and laying the groundwork for
for future stuff
hugely requested feature from the
communities coming up and that is a
complete overhaul to the cop system as
well as vehicle-to-vehicle combat uh it
gives you a whole new feel and dimension
and immersion to the city and enjoying
night city
really excited about it uh watch out for
max tech
there's only so much i'm allowed to say
right now because it's a future update
but we're doing a bunch of stuff in
future updates new kind of gameplay loop
for melee a bunch of new actions in the
in the perk tree more cyberware feeling
cyberware a lot of fun things that the
team really kind of wants to get out
there to the community and working hard
on
all right uh you said that this is the
last major update for uh older gen
consoles can we expect any smaller
updates and tweaks in between definitely
there's gonna be some smaller updates um
primarily focused on tech support to
keep it all running smooth uh but yes
all new future uh features and content
on the current gen consoles as well as
pc okay i will not let y'all off the
hook without telling me more
there's something about the upcoming
expansion you're the game director for
it so what can we expect in that because
everybody's dying to know and i also
want to know so yeah spill the beans all
right all right so
um
we're really excited we're having a lot
of fun with it it's a new kind of uh
style of a plot we're having fun with uh
new cast of characters expanding on a
district in night city uh where it
primarily takes place um we're having
you know what better than me saying
let's show a short teaser clip that was
actually a teaser you brought something
with yes yes oh okay uh so short teaser
to get kind of a vibe and a feel and a
little bit of what's to come check it
out all right let's watch it thank you
for the interview man thank you yeah
let's roll it
repeat after me
i
thee
do solemnly swear
i v
do solemnly swear
that i shall faithfully serve the new
united states of america
that i shall faithfully serve the new
united states of america
on behalf of all americans
i thank you for your service
[Music]
you know taking that oath
bad idea
[Music]
hey everyone
johnny silverhand is coming back and so
am i
get ready for phantom liberty the
upcoming expansion for cyberpunk 2077
it's awesome to be back playing the role
of johnny and i hope you're excited to
see him rock it out once more in the
dark future
keep an eye out for more info
and i'll see you again
in night